so did you see this photo its soleimani
flying home to Iran he's on his flight
his casket is there look at the photo
right now this is his it's apparently
him flying home in his casket caskets in
the seat and people are saying this is
weird is weird for the remains of a
global mass killer to be flown home
commercial in a box but the thing is in
fairness I know people are reacting to
this but in fairness this is how
everybody flies on United now it's the
new policy unless you pay for the living
person upgrade which is just $89.99 by
the way speaking of salamati you know
the media is is still in a state of
mourning over his passing and ABC went
so far as to send a reporter to iran to
very somber ly and and respectfully
cover the terrorist funeral Martha
Raddatz
was on the scene there in Iran and I
think you just need to well you just
need to see this
good morning Rob and I have been in the
midst of anti-american protests in Iran
before but nothing like this a powerful
combination of grief and anger with
shouts of death to America echoing
through the streets around us this
morning mourners filling the streets of
Iran's capital of Tehran for the funeral
of general Soleimani killed by that US
drone strike last week aerial images
capturing the sea of Iranians packing
the streets to pay tribute to a man
revered by many here Trump made a big
mistake gg0
solemn ahni's image everywhere the
impact of his death profound the crowds
are massive and emotional there are many
tears here many signs with solemn
Annie's picture on them but the message
is also very clear these people want
revenge
as we made our way through the streets
of Tehran people surrounding us shouting
death to America
inside the funeral service the emotion
just as powerful the Supreme Leader of
Iran weeping and praying over a coffin
draped in the Iraqi flag this is the
largest funeral in Iran since the death
of the Ayatollah Khomeini in 1989 hard
revenge doesn't sound like a Dolph
Lundgren movie
it sounds like an ad like a b-list
action movie from the 80s hard revenge
but you get the idea anyway this is pure
Iranian propaganda the Iranian
government couldn't have scripted it any
better I mean maybe they did script it I
don't know no mention of the fact that
Soleimani was a murderous scumbag no
mention of him attacking our embassy or
killing our troops no mention of his
oppression and torture of many thousands
of people no instead we get the story of
soleimani the beloved hero now mourned
by milk by millions which as far as that
goes the media has been very impressed
with the turnout for his funeral and for
all the morning or the millions of
people on the street mourning is passing
but remember this is Iran so when you
hear that millions of people are out be
wailing the death of a government
official it's a bit like hearing that
there's a 99.99% voter turnout in North
Korea or something like that it's it's
if you if you don't show up for the the
funeral of the dead government official
you could be taking your life into your
hands so the fact that everybody's out
there I'm not sure we should be
impressed by that by the way side note
maybe you had the same thought when you
were watching that clip there martha has
as you notice the scarf you know the
hijab on her head there which is which
is kind of interesting because of
course in fundamentalist Muslim cultures
women aren't allowed to show their their
heads women really can't show any part
of their body except for their hands and
their faces and in fact in the most
extreme cases they can't even show their
faces and why is that well because a
woman in these cultures a woman is owned
by the men in her life her father and
then her husband and for her to let
anyone see her head aside from her male
owner would be a great sin now feminists
in this country complain about the
patriarchy and about alleged systemic
oppression of women and so on but there
is no patriarchy here there is no
systematic oppression of women women can
do and say whatever they want in this
country they can even as I've gone over
many times they have more rights in this
country than than men do they can do
things they have power and authority
that men do not have in fact very
profound power and authority they they
can kill their children without the
consent of the Father they have power
over life and death judge jury and
executioner that's what they can do in
this country yet in this country they
still feminists still complain that
they're being oppressed and they look
for the patriarchy around every corner
and they try to find every opportunity
they can to label something patriarchal
oppression but then they go to Iran a
truly patriarchal country you want to
know what the patriarchy looks like it
looks like Iran that's what the
patriarchy is you've got a country where
women are really oppressed where they
can't even show their heads in public
and Martha Raddatz goes there and and
she wears the scarf on the head in order
to respect the custom that's what I saw
online that was there was this
discussion on social media about the
fact that she's wearing that and the
defense that I saw for people as well
she's respecting the local customs so if
it's an anti woman custom if it's an
oppressive patriarchal custom you'll
respect it really you don't do that here
or you wouldn't do that here I should
say because there really aren't any
oppressive patriarchal customs here in
this country but you certainly wouldn't
and even many of our customs that are
not at patriarchal or oppressive work
we're told that we don't have to worry
about those customs anymore so what's
this so as long as it's a Muslim custom
then you'll respect it since when do
leftist care about customs
you know that's it's in this country
they couldn't give a damn about custom
custom tradition not only do they not
care about it but they'll say it should
be torn down just for the sake of it you
should tear down old traditions just
because they are old traditions but
Muslim customs even anti-woman ones even
ones that treat your entire body like
it's shameful like it is the the the
owned property of a man while those
customs we have to respect respect those
customs I mean in this country think
about a feminist complain you know that
the patriarchy won't let them go topless
at the beach that's pretty much any time
we talk about it in the past when I
talked about the fact that women have
all the rights that men do in this
country and and even rights that we
don't have and so the fight for women's
rights in this country is over the one
example I'm always given there's always
somebody who says well wait a second
women can women aren't allowed to take
their shirts off in public but men can
which actually I don't even think that's
true anymore I think it pretty much ever
pretty much anywhere you go and what are
most places in this country now it's
it's you know if it's a place where men
can take their shirts off technically
women can - in many places this country
so that's not even really true anymore
but let me just think about that
so in this country that's a custom that
shouldn't be respected
but again the fundamentalist Muslim
custom of in other words if I were to
defend if there are any laws anymore
saying that women can't take their
shirts off in public with men can't if I
were to defend that by saying you know
that's our custom that's our that's our
social convention
in Europe and some other places it's
it's it's a little bit more libertine
but that's not the way that it is in
this country
so if I were to defend it on that basis
no liberal would be convinced by that
because they would demand to know okay
well why is it a custom who cares if
it's a custom not gotta respect it just
because it's a custom
but no you go to a fundamental
fundamentalist Muslim country they put
where they put women in bags essentially
and but that one yes with with with the
utmost reverence we must respect those
customs it's absurd
now you could point out that Raddatz had
to dress that way because if she didn't
she'd be stoned to death and that's fair
that's a fair point i if I were her I
certainly wouldn't want to be stoned to
death either but if you have to submit
to oppression in order to go there and
you're only going there in the first
place to do a puff piece about a
terrorist who died then maybe don't go
maybe don't go and do the puff piece
so you are debasing yourself submitting
the patriarchal oppression
covering yourself in shame just so that
you can go there and tell us what a
wonderful guy this terrorist was
maybe maybe don't that's my thought
maybe don't anyway we're not done yet
with the with the media's mourning
because the media is not done morning
Tom Eliot has put together a montage of
the media wailing over the death of
their hero and it's well again it's just
something you have to see watch this he
was a war hero the commander of Iran's
feared could fourth Qasem Soleimani was
no ordinary general the u.s. officially
classified him as a terrorist but in
Iran he was a national hero he's
regarded as personally incredibly brave
the troops loved him I was trying to
think of somebody I was thinking too
called a revered figure in Iran and some
other places in the Middle East smart
charismatic ruthless strategic and bold
his power made Iranians proud but even
many of sulemani
enemies admitted he was a military
genius Qasem Soleimani was an evil
genius
sulemani was in charge of spreading
Iranian influence around the world and
he was extremely good at it he is the
think of the French Foreign Legion you
know if you will by killing Qasem
Soleimani the US has stripped Iran of an
inspirational military leader the crowds
are massive and emotional there are many
tears here thousands of mullahs on the
streets in Iran symbolic casket the loft
weeping and chanting I am Stella Moni
the Supreme Leader of Iran weeping and
praying over a coffin draped in the
Iraqi flag smart charismatic ruthless
bold strategic do you think that
eulogized bin Laden that way did the
media bin Laden was smart he was
strategic he was bold
he had a following of a lot of people
who loved him yet when he died for some
reason the media didn't use those kinds
of words to describe him did they well
why is that
because it would be completely crazy and
inappropriate and the fact that he's
smart is not the point okay that's
that's not what he's gonna be remembered
for
bin Laden is remembered and will always
be remembered as one of history's great
villains as a mass murderer and so in
this country that's how we eulogize him
or should eulogize them same for
soleimani but the difference is the
reason why the media is using these
kinds of descriptors for Soleimani but
they didn't forbid laden what's the
difference
of course the difference is that bin
Laden was killed under Obama and salami
was solo my salami
so money he was kind of salami now
Soleimani was killed by by under trump
and that's the difference that's the
only difference
of course we know goes without saying
but I'll say it anyway we know that if
this was Trump or if this was Obama who
had done this it would be entirely
different the descriptions of strategic
bold and genius those would be used that
would be applied to Obama and his his
his mission to kill Soleimani that's
that's the way it would go but because
it's Trump now he's not the strategic
poll genius for doing it it's the guy he
killed that was the strategic bold
genius all right and then there's Colin
Kaepernick you know Colin Kaepernick he
wants you to know by the way that he's
still very much oppressed and in
reaction to the killing of Soleimani
Kaepernick sent out a few tweets of his
own which first of all I went to his
Twitter page just to find these tweets
and can we just take a look at his
Twitter page for a second I don't know
if you've seen this but take a look at
it this is what this is I'm not making
this up this is what his Twitter page
looks like he's got eight pictures of
himself at the top of his page his page
is decorated with eight pictures of
himself and every photo has that pensive
thoughtful persecuted look to it it's
it's amazing I mean how did that
conversation even go he's a social media
manager or whatever you know said the
Kaepernick hey we we got your page set
up and we've got your header with a
really nice photo of you I think you'll
like it check it out he says no it needs
needs more me
okay so we'll add another photo no more
so okay we'll put three photos up of you
more five more more more more me put up
all the photos all the photos of me put
them all up there anyway so to his uh
his his very narcissistically adorned
twitter page he posted a few tweets and
this is what he said he said there is
nothing new about american terrorist
there is nothing new about american
terrorist attacks against black and
brown people for the expansion of
American imperialism
and then he said America has always
sanctioned and besieged black and brown
bodies both at home and abroad American
militarism is the weapon wielded by
American imperialism to enforce its
policing and plundering of a non-white
world so killing Soleimani who was who
was tortured and murdered murdered
thousands in his life not just white
people by the way
that is a terrorist attack against brown
people we're told
America is always sanctioning and
besieging black and brown people he says
well let's let's think about this how
has Kaepernick himself been sanctioned
and besieged by America let's take a
look at that Kaepernick was paid to play
a game for six years
and during that time he made well over
40 million dollars then he flunks out of
the league because his production is
declining and he's not worth the trouble
anymore once he starts with it with the
anthem antics it becomes a PR nightmare
and nobody wants to bother with him and
so he leaves he leaves the league he
flunks out ends up signing a deal with
Nike worth millions and millions of
dollars and then he sues the NFL and
gets paid something reportedly in the
range of 60 to 80 million dollars and
then Nike just a few weeks ago or a few
months ago released a Capra Dick's new
shoe he's got a shoe coming out he's got
his own shoe even though he's a failed
NFL player he's not an athlete anymore
he's a professional victim but he's got
his own shoe so this is sanctioning and
besieging to be a professional football
player turned professional victim
obscenely rich famous hailed by the
media millions of fans adore him as a
hero for doing nothing at all really
this is sanctioning and besieging this
is the persecution that Kaepernick has
suffered all I can say is and I'm sure
you're with me on this please somebody
beseech me in this way I would love to
be besieged with a hundred million
dollars please I beg someone persecute
me in the way that Colin Kaepernick is
would persecute it I would I would I
would love that kind of persecution that
you know there's there's a lot of
persecution that goes on in the world
that doesn't look quite so fun but but
the Kaepernick persecution
yeah I I think I would I think I could
go for that I could get used to that all
right let's take a look at this speaking
of frauds and charlatans Jim Baker
Jim Baker is a televangelist convicted
fraudster accused rapist allegedly raped
his secretary back in the 80s paid her
off was kicked out of ministry then gets
convicted on multiple counts of mail
fraud wire fraud conspiracy went to
prison for that
and basically through his whole career
he's it's just been one scandal after
another most of the scandals are sexual
or financial in nature but he's back to
being a televangelist now somehow
somehow people still go and listen to
this guy
deliver sermons the other good news is I
guess if we're gonna give old
Baker a credit for one thing he's not a
prosperity gospel preacher anymore used
to he used to be a prosperity gospel
charlatan back in the 80s before he went
to prison and he and that's the that's
the idea that if you're really holy and
you pray a lot God will give you lots of
money and make you rich which means that
of course if you're not rich if you're
poor it means that you're not holy and
you haven't prayed enough so that used
to be his thing but he went to prison
and he says that he read his Bible in
prison and he realized he was wrong so
this is a guy who's I think he's 80
years old now and I believe and he went
to prison and he was in the prison in
the 90s early 90s so he read his Bible
all the way through for the first time
when he was what like 50 he been in
ministry his whole life finally in his
50s he says you know what maybe I'll
pick this thing up and read it so he
just read it recently only recently
realized what's even in the Bible yet
people still go to him to hear his
theological opinions I think he got out
of prison in like 94 95 got back into
ministry in 2003 or four so it's only
been eight years since this 50-plus year
old man even read his Bible and he's a
televangelist people are going back to
him to hear what he has to say about
theology it's amazing and he delivered
one of those theological opinions this
week let's take a listen to it
you know what Trump is a test whether
you're even sane mmm-hmm only safe
people can love Trump know you gotta be
really save you got to forgive you got
to be able to forget you forgive when
you're saved so there you go if you
don't love Trump you aren't saved
that's Baker's new grill
you know you see he just moved on from
one scam to the other his old scam was
prosperity theology that didn't work he
took his own advice a little bit too
much ended up in federal prison and he
gets out and eventually reinvents
himself and his theology starts
pandering to the Trump crowd starts
getting more political realizes there's
an audience there and now he says that
no wealth is not the test of whether
you're saved Trump is the test so it's a
it's a it's not a it's not an economic
or financial literacy test that gets you
into heaven it's a political one
God's gonna check your scorecard check
your voting record decide based on that
all I could say is you know obviously
it's not worth our time to break this
down and explain why this charlatan
fraud scamming
so on and so forth is wrong about this
it's not worth the time but it does just
bring up again you know this this guy
has an audience
people who watch him on TV people that
go to to to uh to his you know whatever
listen to him speak why it is such and
he's not the only one of course you know
there's a there's a lot of them out
there
of these blatantly obvious charlatans
and frauds
who are manipulating
and and just saying whatever they have
to do to gain a following and enriching
themselves and using the Bible and the
the this cloak of Christianity to do it
and it's so obvious what they're doing
yet millions of Christians fall for it
it is such an indictment
it isn't it's an indictment on the the
lack of depth and intelligence
so many American Christians and I'm
sorry to put it that way I don't I don't
I hate that that is the fact but it is
the fact
and maybe I shouldn't even say
intelligence because I think that looks
people off the hook if people that go
and listen to Baker to say that they're
stupid I wish that it was just a matter
of stupidity because you know you can't
help being stupid but it's more than
that you're being willfully deceived so
I actually in fact I'm gonna amend that
statement it's not it's not a matter of
intelligence because I'm not to let
anybody off the hook I think these are
people who are being willfully deceived
because they go and listen to this guy
because they they get something out of
it that they like
he's tickling their ears he sang things
that they want to hear he's giving them
a version of Christianity that they like
and that's why they go to him and at
some level they must know because
they're not stupid they must know that
this is all BS and that this guy's a
wolf in sheep's code they they must know
it
so I hold them accountable to
and before it was okay you go to
somebody like Baker
because of the prosperity theology and
he says and he promised use you wealth
and riches if you pray the right way and
of course that's gonna be appealing to
people and so that's why they go to him
and they're willing to overlook all this
stuff he's like he's convicted of fraud
he's a convicted fraudster then we're
gonna overlook that because he's telling
us what we want to hear well he you know
he decides that's not so popular anymore
so I'm not gonna do that anymore and
remember and also prosperity theology
the heyday of prosperity theology was in
the eighties the 70s and 80s in in
recent years a lot of people have woken
up to the scam and other people in
Christian in in the church are fighting
back against it so it's not so popular
anymore I don't think it's a coincidence
that Baker had his come to Jesus moment
literally he had his a realization right
around the time when prosperity theology
wasn't popular as popular as it used to
be
so he realizes this not-so-popular comes
up with a new scam
and this time it's more political and
everything and and he's like a
Republican televangelist now
and so people who are Republican they
like to hear this that's great I mean if
you're already a Trump supporter right
you would and this guy says oh you're
saved if you support Trump that's nice
to hear
yeah but you know it's wrong
you know you must know it and we got to
do better than this
we just have to
and I don't want to hear it you know
what and I know I'm gonna get emails
from people saying oh well what about
forgiveness Matt shouldn't we forgive
him yeah he went to jail yeah he's a
convicted fraudster and liar he went to
prison was originally was supposed to go
to prison for like 40 years and got out
I mean she should still be in jail right
now and yeah he paid off a woman that he
allegedly raped and so on but we should
forgive we forgive I don't want to hear
that okay
this this forgiveness thing has become
such a cop-out it's become this sort of
such a broad concept it's supposed to be
a get-out-of-jail-free card for people
and it's not first of all what does it
mean if you're not directly affected by
something bad that somebody did you
realize that you forgiving them means
nothing what do you mean you forgive
them so a guy commits fraud
you know scams people out of money and
you are not one of the people who got
scammed out of money and you forgive him
I mean you it's not up to you to forgive
it's like if a guy's a serial rapist and
and you say oh I forgive him I forgive
him you weren't a victim if you're not a
victim and you're not a family that what
do you mean what does it mean for you to
forgive him what does that even mean
it's not up to you to forgive
and it costs you nothing to forget it's
really easy to do it yes I could sit
here in fact right now I'm gonna sit
here I'm gonna wave my hand and I'm
gonna forgive everyone who's ever done
anything bad that didn't affect me I I
forgive all of you yeah every single one
of you yeah I forgive you I mean there's
a guy in Chicago right now stealing
somebody else's car
I forgive that guy I forgive him go in
peace you have my blessing what does
that mean
doesn't mean anything forgiveness is
something that you do that you offer to
someone who is wrong to you personally
it's the same thing with a
turn-the-other-cheek how we're supposed
to turn the other cheek yeah turn the
other cheek is when you are personally
offended or insulted or attacked and you
respond that way to your own but if
someone else is attacked
um and you don't respond to it
sit back and let it happen you can't say
oh I was turning the other cheek it's
not your cheek it's really easy for you
to turn it when you're not the one
getting slapped so it's a similar thing
with forgiveness which doesn't mean that
I'm not I'm not saying that we should
hold that we should sit hold grudges or
that we should not allow people to
change their ways and so on that's not
my point
I'm just saying forgiveness is easy and
cheap when you are not the one affected
by it second point about forgiveness
just because you forgive someone doesn't
mean that you trust them again doesn't
mean that you go to them as an authority
especially a moral authority ever again
it doesn't mean that you forget what
they did it doesn't mean you allow
yourself to get scammed by this person
that's not what it means
so Jim Baker convicted fraudster yes go
ahead and forgive him whatever the hell
that means if you're not a if you were
not a victim of one of his many crimes
so go ahead go ahead forgive him that
doesn't mean that you should go and
listen to him as a moral or theological
authority
and in fact if he was actually serious
in his in his if he was actually
repentant and penitent he wouldn't be
putting himself up as a moral and
Theological Authority he would have
gotten out of prison and went off into
obscurity and moved into the mountains
or something and and and lived in
penance for the rest of his life because
he would have realized that he is not
that he is not capable of being a being
that in that position that he had
betrayed people's trust in such a way in
such an egregious way that it would be
wrong for him to put himself in that
position again that's what he would do
if he was really penitent but no he gets
he hops right back on the saddle
making money again off of off of
distorting the gospel
and you think that's penitent now
not at all
I mean it's just like if I mean M'Vila
forgiveness you know if if a spouse
cheats on you
you find a way to forgive them locating
well now that's that's a real heroic
feat I mean that's meaningful if you can
actually forgive your spouse for
cheating on you forgive forgive someone
else's spouse for cheating on them that
doesn't mean anything for you to do that
good good job nicely done good for you
but so forgive your own spouse oh yeah
very very uh takes a lot but
that doesn't mean that you automatically
trust them again
and it doesn't mean you know and there
are gonna be things like probably if
they've if they've cheated on you and
you're trying to rebuild the marriage
they're gonna be things like okay now
you you can't have the same sort of
privacy online that you had before okay
I'm gonna be suspicious if you're
locking your phone down if I you know if
I'm trying to go on if you're making
sure that you're logged at a Facebook or
something before I go and use the
computer I mean things like that I'm
gonna be suspicious not because I
haven't forgiven you but because I'm not
stupid
and I know that this is something that
you've done in the past and that you
apparently are prone to
all right let's okay let's move on I
have a bunch of emails to answer but
first okay well my wife went to an
organic grocery store actually it was it
was it was called the or the organic
mommy market I think she said or mom's
organic market or something like that
something longer one of those places
where you go there and you buy a jar of
home and butter for $43 one of those
things and she comes home with with
these I don't know if you could see that
there these are this is a bag of
crickets barbecue crickets
and she dares me to eat them on my show
to do a taste test of the crickets on my
show and this is pretty evil on her part
I have to say because she knows she she
damn well knows that I have the maturity
of a 12 year old and so when you say to
me I dare you to do this
i double-dog dare you she knows that I
have to do it I can't not do it even
though I'm a 33 year old man allegedly
if I'm dared to do something I feel like
I have to do it my six-year-old son can
and has coaxed me into doing things that
were not necessarily smart just by
daring me to do them so that's that's
where I'm at and so she says that and
that means I have to do it but as it
happens
she didn't even really need to dare me
to do this because bugs are all the rage
these days it's very environmentally
friendly everyone's talking about how
you're supposed to eat bugs and as you
guys know I care deeply about
environmentalism it's an issue that's
near and dear to my heart it's probably
my number one issue in life as you know
I talk about it all the time and so this
is something that you know I feel
morally obliged to do I just hope that
these are free-range crickets
because I only need it I only eat
insects that are free-range open swords
grass-fed Buddhists by the way but this
is just to give a shout out to the
company this is the company called bug
Bistro BBQ crickets these are barbecue
flavor crickets from an tomo farms it
looks like and there is a there is a
warning very helpful warning on the back
of this it says allergy warning contains
insects so if you're wondering if the
bag of insects contains insects it does
the bag of insects doesn't contain
skittles it turns out it does contain
insects so all right well let's let's
give these a try first of all they do it
you know what it the bag of crickets it
smells like a bag of crickets it pretty
much smells exactly like you would
expect if I were to blindfold you and
put this in front of your nose you would
say hmm smells like a bag of crickets
and you would be exactly right
so let's let's stop stalling and give
these a shot this could be life-changing
I mean if I discover that I love these
things I can just go outside any time
grab some crickets and have a nice snack
so they do look like crickets too got
the eyes still there
you know they haven't they haven't
really tried to pretty these things up
at all yeah you know so the taste it's
got a little bit of a little bit of a
nutty almond taste oh definitely very
there's a very very distinct almond
flavor there
it tastes a little bit like there's a
little bit of almond there's a little
bit of mud and there's a whole lot of
cricket
yeah tastes a little bit like if you
were to walk outside in them in the mud
then come back inside take your shoe off
smother the bottom of the shoe and
barbecue sauce and lick it that's sort
of the taste not terrible not good I'll
tell you the worst thing about it
the taste is and you know the taste is
not so bad on a pure taste scale I would
say it's it's a it's about a level above
taco bell which isn't hard to do but
what makes the experience somewhat
horrifying is the anatomical aspect of
it where you can really feel and taste
all the different parts of the cricket
exploding in your mouth
and that's that that part I don't really
enjoy as much to be honest
I wonder what happens if I just so I
just tried to head there you know what
the heads not so bad I think I'm more of
a head guy I think I think I like the
head but but the rep because the rest of
the body that's where you get all the
legs and everything in the wings plus
when you eat the head you get the you
you absorb the brain the tiny little
brain of the insect and so you'll
believe scientifically you absorb the
insects IQ and so after about three or
four of them you'll be as smart as
Alexandria okay zero Cortez which is
which is nice so that's insects I am I
think I still prefer to eat cows instead
as as as somewhat tolerable as these are
I think I would just prefer to stick
with beef but that's that's just me
and I am what I am wondering how much
these costs because this was at an
organic market
and I don't even want to ask my wife but
I'm afraid that when I ask her she's
gonna tell me there were 27 dollars for
a bag of bugs yeah the aftertaste not so
great either very crickety aftertaste
all right let's move on this is from
let's go to emails Matt wall show at
gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
now I have the cricket part stuck in my
teeth and in my throat
not pleasant not very pleasant this is
from Janice says hey Matt just a heads
up never attend a mass in Argentina
my mother is from there so I have
first-hand experience if you however
decide to ignore my advice you'll be
expected to not just shake people's
hands but to also hug them Argentinian
men kiss each other in the cheek most
Argentinians are of Italian descent so
there's that and Pope Francis knows that
of course but this Pope is a comedy so
he's fine with Castro and Maduro
grabbing his hands but lashes out when
someone else does it you know
janna I kind of appreciate that and I
got a few emails we talked about the
sign of the Peace in Catholic Mass last
week and yeah I heard from other people
from other countries saying oh you know
in our country it's it's even worse than
that
there's hugging and kissing I appreciate
that
now don't get me wrong it's horrific if
I ended up in a church where they did
that I just become a jehovah's witness
on the spot but what I'm saying is if
you're going to take a break in the
action randomly to let people exchange
signs of peace whatever that means you
may as well go full tilt I mean you
might as well really go for it because
the awkward formal American thing with
the handshake where you're just peace be
with you yes and with you yes yes peace
be with you
peace be with you or you're just barely
grabbing the person's hand it sort of
defeats the purpose so at least with the
Argentinians they really I mean when
they give the sign of peace
they really give it and so that I as
horrible as it is I I can appreciate
that this is from Nicolas as hi Matt
greetings from the land of spiders and
unfortunately right now fire I wanted
your thoughts on the I've got crickets
on the desk here I wanted your thoughts
and I still got crickets stuck in my
throat right now as I'm as I'm this is
can't they at least can't they at least
tear the legs off these things before
they put them in the bag greetings from
the land of spiders and unfortunately
right now fire I wanted your thoughts on
the theological considerations of these
fires last year a famous Australian
sports star said that the fires were
God's punishment for same-sex marriage
and abortion both are legal in Australia
but we also have the rare distinction
alongside Ireland of approving same-sex
marriage and a popular vote which
happens in 2017 do you think he's right
so are the okay so the question is that
fires in Australia are they a punishment
for God from same-sex marriage first of
all Nicholas I'm sorry for what you guys
are going through down there in
Australia it really is unbelievable the
extent of these fires
is it divine punishment no absolutely
not I think that's that's ridiculous
really big fires like this happen in
Australia because it's hot and dry and
and and and that's why it happens if God
was gonna torch countries that allow
same-sex marriage
so you mentioned Ireland why isn't
Ireland on fire well you could say
Ireland is wet and cold so they don't
really get forest fires like like other
countries like like Australia does but
if this is divine action and the
physical the physical conditions don't
matter do you think God needs it to be
the right physical condition in order to
start a fire this is God we're talking
about God could set Ireland on fire if
you wanted to and yet he doesn't and in
fact I think if you were to see a be
like if Ireland were to be on fire to
the extent of Australia that would be
quite a statement I mean you'd almost be
forced to come up with some supernatural
explanation for it but it just so
happens I guess that the places that God
decides to punish with a fire are also
the places where fires always happen
anyway and the place where even fires of
this magnitude have happened in the past
even before same-sex marriage so that's
the problem with saying that a natural
disaster is some kind of punishment from
God because they happen all across the
world
natural disasters do at random places
affecting everyone randomly and and and
they've always happened everywhere
natural disasters have there's no
observable connection between a country
acting immorally and natural disasters
so we'd really don't observe that we
don't observe that as a country descends
into immorality natural disasters become
more common we don't put on them that's
that is not what we observe I think what
Christians try to do with this is very
similar to what leftist do by blaming it
on global warming again you can't blame
it on global warming because Australia
has always had bush fires and they've
and they've had really bad ones in the
past also it might maybe it's been a
while since they had one like this but
it has happened there was a bush fire in
1927 1926 I think that killed 30-plus
people there was a bush fire in the 90
30s that killed 70 plus people but way
back in the 20s and 30s the very few
people were driving there weren't you
didn't have nearly the same number of
factories and the industrialization that
we have now to the same extent the same
degree and yet these things happen back
then so you you really again you don't
observe this steady increase in
bushfires
to go along with so-called global
warming and just and it's the same thing
with people that try to make it a divine
punishment and I get and I think this is
probably the most prescient point here
actually is that and I should have
mentioned this before the fires in
Australia right now many of them have
been deliberately set by people last I
read 200 people have been arrested in
Australia for setting fires so you can't
blame it on climate change it wasn't
climate change that made them set the
fire on purpose it wasn't God who made
them do it they did it on their own and
so that's how I would respond that by
the way since we're on the subject and
and yes as we talked about the fires are
really bad it's a terrible situation but
the media is doing quite a lot of
sensationalizing because they want to to
draw this connection between this and
global warming so I want you to look at
this this is this is pretty incredible
here's a map this is a map that ABC
posted yesterday and this supposedly
shows the scale of the fires in
Australia that red stuff around the
edges according to ABC
that's all fire
now now let me let me show you another
map this is a map of Australia's
population density and you see where all
the population centres are in Australia
and you see how they're around the
coastlines there what do you notice
according to this according to ABC
anyway every but almost everybody in
Australia is on fire right now
so everyone is dead according to ABC you
see all the places where there's
population all of that is on fire which
of course is not the case I think that
the actual death toll is 25 or 30 at
this point which is horrible it's
obviously a terrible thing and and but
that's what makes it so atrocious when
the when the media sensationalizes
because you don't not only is it
unethical and immoral and you're lying
but it's not necessary the actual
situation is really really bad so you
don't have to make it up you could just
report what's actually happening it's
the same thing with mass shootings and
school shootings you see the media
trying to pump up the numbers by saying
oh there are 200 mass shootings a year
or whatever crazy number they come up
with no it's not anywhere close to that
but they do happen and they're really
terrible and so you don't need to do
this
putting aside how unethical and immoral
it is it's also it's so unnecessary
you could stick to the facts and the
facts themselves are horrific enough on
their own they don't need your
embellishment
let's see I'll do one once from Andrew
says great show love your commentary I
enjoy and have for the most part always
enjoyed comedians like Gervaise Chappell
and Rogen however I find that as much as
we like to lift them up right now as we
side with them against the outraged
culture the Catholic predator jokes and
atheistic attacks all we've struck me
the wrong way
is this an inability to take a joke on
my part or would you want these jokes to
be gone from the repertoire for better
enjoyment hey this is an interesting
point I saw somebody online yesterday
say hey conservatives Ricky Gervais
isn't on our side he's not a
conservative and that's true he's not
he's Ricky Gervais is pro-abortion
socially liberal extremely atheist his
stand-up act I've watched a couple of
his stand-up acts and I think he's very
funny I think he's really talented not
just as a committee I think he's more
talented even as a you know as a in
creating shows and ran as a scriptwriter
for TV shows but anyway this atheism is
a big part of what he does and his
stand-up act consists of at least the
ones ISIL it's like 80% jokes about
religious people but that's actually why
I appreciate him because he's not
pandering he really is an equal
opportunity offender Joe Rogan also was
atheist and very outspoken about that
but I appreciate that because number one
you're being honest about how you feel
and what you think and I think we need
that in this country even if I disagree
I mean at this point I'm at a point
right now
where
so tired of the pandering that happens
on both sides I'm so tired of the same
old thing from everybody everyone just
the same talking points it's just how
redundant and repetitive everything is
and how safe everybody is you know you
find your tribe or your side and you
stick to those talking points you don't
want to upset them you always want so
I'm at a point where I can appreciate
anyone who is actually honest about how
they feel and thinks for themselves and
isn't worried about cultivating a tribe
or sticking to a tribes talking points
but it's just it just says look this is
how I feel is what I think
some of it is gonna be consistent with
what this camp says some of its gonna be
with this camp I don't care this is just
what I think so I appreciate that and I
also appreciate that you know somebody
like Richard Ricky Gervais
he is liberal yet he's up there calling
out his own people
and I respect that as well so you know
it doesn't yeah I mean if if I'm gonna
sit and watch a comedian what I prefer
if they don't spend 25 of the 45-minute
set making fun of Christians yeah I mean
I'd prefer it personally but
I guess my point is the fact that
somebody like that with that viewpoint
got up at the Golden Globes
and did what he did I think that's more
powerful
fact that he's a socially liberal
atheist
even he's up there sang this to these
people
that makes it more power it's more
powerful than if some conservative
Christian had done it not that a
conservative Christian would ever be
invited to host the Golden Globes in the
first place but that's the point we need
people in that world
to you know speak out against some of
this stuff
all right we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening
go get your bug Bistro crickets today
and enjoy them and I'll talk to you
tomorrow
got the Matt Walsh show is produced by
Sean Hampton executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Sterling
technical producer austin stevens editor
donovan fowler audio mixer robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]